c'est notre première émission poste
césar 2020 une édition était extrêmement
mouvementée je prends un adjectif modéré
à savoir ce que vous a inspiré ce grand
branle-bas du cinéma français où là
aussi des tas de choses l'état de thèmes
se sont emmêlés pendant cette cérémonie
de remise
je trouve que vous l'avez vécu moi j'ai
pas trouvé c'est catastrophique j'ai
trouvé que s'est reflété aussi un
changement dans la société
la parole changent mais pas seulement
aux césar c'est un épiphénomène presse
dans la société
on peut plus violer impunément dans le
sport en politique en tout cas la parole
sort c'est une période quasi pas
révolutionnaire alors comme toutes ces
perles de large
la parole est pas toujours intelligible
elle est parfois paradoxales n'est pas
toujours intelligentes oui les césars
s'était pas de l'amour mais c'était
peut-être mieux que glamour avec ardeur
weinstein dans la salle je sais pas ce
que j'en sais que dire passer par là
pour il faut toujours passer après c'est
comme dans toutes les révolutions
j'écoute beaucoup en ce moment je relis
plein de choses moi je que ce dont j'ai
peur c'est que dans les révolutions il
ya les mencheviks les bolchéviques et
tout ça c'est que et pas seulement la
réaction c'est y est l'intolérance et
qu'on ne s'écoutent plus et moi je pense
que fanny ardant a le droit de dire ce
qu'elle pense qu'après claire denis a le
droit d'écrire ce qu'elles pensent que
leurs bras feuilleton dont le parti doit
lancer son droit on est en démocratie
c'est notre faut la préserver faut la
sauver toujours est il ya une phrase de
camus tu très ému parce que j'adore cet
auteur qui dit qu' on ne peut pas
refaire le monde mais il faut se battre
pour que que le monde ne se défasse pas
et aujourd'hui je pense que c'est ça
qu'il faut faire et je me permets dadais
dans de rebondir sa sujet qui m'a
beaucoup moi beaucoup touché beaucoup
mis en colère et je suis assez content
de ce qui s'est passé dans la sphère
polanski finalement on cesse de en fin
de de faire cette distinction honteuse
il était avancé que par cinéma on
distingue l'artiste de l'homme n'ont pas
digéré
on a le droit à l'erreur
raciste antisémite et d'artistes
homophobes ça fait partie de l'homme
aussi je pense que vous écoutez les la
slimani qui parlait à france inter cette
semaine je suis dit voilà et qui parle
justement qu'à un moment donné l'oeuvre
dépasse le créateur n'a pas prêt pas
c'est la porte ouverte à benoît martel
connaît maintenant quand vous dites il
faut juger des oeuvres pour ce qu'elles
sont parce que sinon faut tour en juger
l'histoire
en revanche il faut que la justice passe
et fo cadres einer richard wagner et est
une ordure mais ces mythes
son oeuvre est admirable daniel
barenboim terrible a dirigé richard
wagner ferdinand louis céline est une
ordure antisémite
ça n'empêche pas fabrice luchini mais je
vous engage à prêter de l'année franck
et un quai branly lycée c'est moi il
faut se lever
j'explique c'est qui me semble qu'on est
tous réunis ici pour défendre la culture
et le sens la racine même de la culture
c'est que quelqu'un qui humainement peut
être sublime extraordinaire sera
peut-être nul
artistiquement ne sera pas capable de
sortir de lui à une empreinte pour tout
roule pour l'humanité qui va suivre
alors que quelqu'un qui est de la pure
ordure comme eux l'étaient a pu sortir
une oeuvre meerab et de saint haon je
pense que le devoir d'un artiste quel
qu'il soit c'est justement de séparer et
c'est ça qui fait la beauté de l'homme
d'être une bête et en même temps d'être
avec vous et se laver ou parler d'une
posture de penser
prosys vous parlez d'une posture de
kebede d'avis il est l extra primaire
louis ferdinand céline l'elysée n'ont
jamais remporté et oui ferdinand ces
marais je le suis a discuté avec marcel
aymé je sais pas ce qui s'est passé il
ya dix ans régis michel quand je vends
doué dont il a traité du nombre d'actes
oui c'est pas lui qui a déporté les
juifs hors polanski il a été quand même
accusé de différentes choses donc il a
fait des choses il ya pensé les choses
horribles
on peut condamner aujourd'hui y aller
faire d'accord c'est très différent
crédit fait jamais et je maintiens que
polanski aurait été raciste antisémite
homophobe il n'aurait horaire serré hier
qu'il a fait dans le cinéma et que dans
le cinéma on tolère cette maltraitance
féminine
je suis contente a dit personnellement
dans la patrie si j'y vais me permettre
d'intervenir moi je suis pour que le
justiciable sisti ça réponde de ses
actes mais on n'arrive pas à inscrire on
n'arrive pas à mettre la main sur le
justiciable donc on est sept mois à
venir l'artiste je comprends pas ce
raisonnement
polanski a été condamné aux états unis
et ensuite a fait une carrière
tranquillement avec beaucoup de
récompenses en étant condamnée et
maintenant qu'il est seulement accusé il
faudrait ou boycotter ces filous lui
interdire de recevoir des récompenses
je ne comprends pas cette absurdité
pourquoi un homme condamné peut faire
carrière et un homme accusé vous avez le
vrai mais cela leur karim et quelques
jours d'itt et vous avez les mêmes rêves
volés réaliser les bêtes qu'eux avaient
des nets se lève et que virgine
despentes parle comme ça dans libération
aux efforts c'est indispensable
aujourd'hui pour qu'il y ait des figures
auxquelles on peut s'identifier ou
qu'elles n'ont accès à la parole à la
culture on peut parler il ya des gens
qui sont encore des victimes
peut-être y at-il encore des abuseurs
certains aujourd'hui il y en a une et
cinq pages de boycotter polanski fera ça
fait parler aujourd'hui ça fait ça va
aujourd'hui sienne après on n'a pas
entendu ni kohler n'a pas entendu naroui
j'ai tourné avec beaucoup de
réalisatrice avec beaucoup d'actrices et
moi j'ai jamais rien vu de ce qui aurait
pu se passer d'abus ou de quoi que ce
soit voilà pas croire que tout le monde
dans le cinéma y a que des gros porcs
n'ont plus à presser je trouve ça voilà
c'était complètement nécessaire de faire
ça je comprends pas pourquoi on lui a
donné un prix mois après il ya des
votants on n'est pas là pour rendre un
verdict tombe pas des juges comme des
éclairs denis voilà après claire de
l'eca lui le truc voilà c'est un verbe
c'était ce n'était pas un verdict de jeu
c'était juste donné les votes en fait
après que ce soit arrivé là oui je
trouve ça complètement scandaleux et ça
m'a révolté souhait puis je comprends
complètement adele qui est parti et puis
le le pamphlet de virginie après mais il
fallait que ça se passe et met tout le
cinéma n'est pas comme ça qu'on sait
rien de temps en effet c'est que ces
figures là comme adel comme virginie
quoi comment s'exprime par ce que il ya
des gens qui ne peuvent pas ils peuvent
pas s'exprimer et au moins celle c'est
ça c'est leur porte parle entre
guillemets ou ça peut libérer des choses
et ça fait un débat voilà pourtant c'est
le débat que d'un seul coup il montre à
réagir à ça et on a souvent accusé le
cinéma d'être une bulle déconnecté du
monde entier avec raison
cette soirée-là a prouvé qu apparemment
ce mec a apparemment le plus qu'à moi
j'ai l'impression
ouais non non pascale oriot dit quelque
chose de très intéressant sur le côté
révolution en fait si on réfléchit bien
la révolution quand la légitimité se
s'oppose à la légalité et légitimité qui
considère que la loi est faite de telle
sorte qu'elles aient bringuebalante et
qui a des déficiences et effectivement
cette légitimité révolutionnaire est
appelée elle même un jour à devenir
légal oui et c'est dans cette égalité
que peuvent se poser les problèmes soit
la légitimité qui était de bonne foi
devient abusive et ça donne le
communisme soit cette légitimité devient
est toujours de bonne foi et elle
s'incarne dans quelque chose qu'on aime
bien que la démocratie mais le passage
il ya l'égalité anciennes contre
légitimité nouvelle et ensuite il ya les
gyms une nouvelle contre legalis et
l'égalité nouvelle au carré et on est
encore dans la société là où la
légitimité du 21e siècle casse la figure
toute la journée la légalité du 20e et
je serai demain j'espère que ça va
donner une légalité du 21e et qui perd
permettra de ne plus assister à des
césar
parce que le jeu dit pas que le fascisme
est à nos portes mais il faut faire
attention à ce qu'on m'en faut rester
vigilant
[Applaudissements]